Speaker 1: Carrie Lake spoke at least twice at
CPAC based on the number of outfit changes. She
said a lot of extremely bizarre things. I
don't know how much longer Carrie Lake has
to be paid attention to Now, if she does run for
Senate in Arizona in 2024. She will get another
round of attention. But here is Carrie Lake,
crowning Stephen Bannon, the Fox, the indicted
and convicted for Breitbart propaganda, Steve
Bannon. She says he's like George Washington.
Speaker 3: Steve Bannon is somewhere in
the crowd. Yeah. Where's that patriot?
There he is. I love that man. He's
a modern day George Washington.
Speaker 1: In what way? Really, really weird.
And as we as you know, Kerry Lake is one of the
sickest people in politics right now. At another
moment during one of her two CPAC speeches, she
talked about how God told her all about the things
she's doing. And it really sounds like the type of
thing that should be explored in therapy, quite.
Speaker 3: Frankly, places at this moment for
a reason. I talked about my moment with
God where he told me, you're going to do
something special someday.
Speaker 1: Someday.
Speaker 3: And I don't know what it is. It
may still be to come. Who knows? But I know
that putting me in the center of all of this
with my fighting spirit, I believe that God
is truly in control at this moment. And we
win. I believe we win at the end of the day.
Speaker 1: He plays mild applause for that. And
part of it is that her she didn't have big crowds.
Speaker 3: Just here for a reason, Right? He
doesn't make accidents. He doesn't he doesn't
accidentally places where we are. We are here for
a reason, just the same as our founding fathers
at that pivotal moment where place where they were
in 1776, right here, Sam Adams, Patrick Henry. And
what we're facing right now is no different.
Speaker 1: Yeah. In the same way that God
placed Paul Revere in a position to be one of the
founders, he placed Kerry Lake in a position to,
I guess, lose the governorship of Arizona.
And then lastly, and again, this seems to
be a different Kerry like speech because she's
wearing different clothes. She is now telling
the story that someone tried to bribe her out of
politics. Tell me if you believe this story that.
Speaker 3: Happened to me this week before I left
for CPAC. And it shows how desperate these people
are to stop me and to silence you, I decided
to share this. It's a little bit controversial,
but I'm going to put this out. Somebody showed
up at my door. Whoa! This week. They called me
before and said, I got to talk to you in person.
This can't be done over the phone. She's always
kind of like, Oh, what's that going to be about?
They came to my door and they tried to bribe me
out of getting out of politics.
Speaker 1: And they said, Sir.
Speaker 3: It's really happened.
Speaker 1: Now, by the way. Did
you listen to the exact word she used? Listen to.
Speaker 3: That. They called me before and said,
I got to talk to you in person. This can't be
done over the phone. She's always kind of like,
Oh, what's that going to be about?
They came to my door and they tried
to bribe me out of getting out of politics.
Speaker 1: She Now, that's not what she means.
She's her control. Command of the English language
is so poor. She said they tried to bribe me,
bribe me out of getting out of politics. In other
words, they wanted to pay her to stay in politics.
But that's not what she actually means. It's
another one of these accidental double negatives.
And you'd think for someone who spent so much time
talking on TV, she would be able to better explain
herself. But anyway, she doesn't mean bribe me out
of getting out of politics. She means they tried
to bribe me out of politics. Okay.
Speaker 3:
It's really happened. I'm telling you this
because this is how disgusting politics is. A mom
who runs for office and they're afraid of
me. They tried to bribe me with a job title
with a huge salary, a position on a board. This
is how they do it. And I said, Are you kidding
me? I walked away from a big job and a big
salary. I'm not motivated by that stuff, guys.
Speaker 1: All right. Anyway, so she'll hopefully
keep losing elections, but Kerry Flake out of out
of this world. Do you believe that story that she
just told? I have a real hard time believing it.
All of these clips will be on our YouTube channel,
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. Make sure
you are subscribed, folks. Hit that subscribe
button on the YouTube channel. And remember,
you can find these clips in Spanish
at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.